this next story is the the the teacher
let's talk about the teacher with the uh
teacher that sent that uh message out by
the way for the people that follow
snopes i don't care whether this is true
or if it's not true
all i care about the principle of the
story is absolutely fascinating i read
this the other day it says
the teacher fails the entire class okay
teacher fails an entire class an
economic professor at a local college
made a statement that she had never
failed a single student before but had
recently failed an entire class that
class had insisted that socialism worked
and that no one else would be poor and
no one would be rich a great equalizer
the professor said okay
we will have an ex experiment in this
class on this plan all grades will be
averaged and everyone will receive the
same grade no one else will fail and no
one will receive an a substituting
grades for dollars something closer to
home and more readily understood at all
after the first test the grades were
average and everyone got to be the
students who studied hard were upset and
the students who studied little were
happy at the second test rolled around
the students who studied little had
studied even less and the ones who had
studied hard decided they were they
wanted a free ride too so they studied
little the second test average was a d
no one was happy when the third test
rolled around the average was an f as a
test proceeded the scores never
increased as bickering blame and name
calling all result and hard feelings and
no one would study for the benefit of
anyone else to their great surprise all
filled and the pro professors told them
that socialism would also be ultimately
fail when the reward is great the
efforts succeed etcetera etcetera then
he makes five she makes five points okay
these are the five points you cannot
legislate the poor into prosperity by
legislating the wealthy out of
prosperity we've heard that before
number two
what one person receives without working
for another person must work for without
receiving number three the government
cannot give to anybody anything that the
government does not first take from
someone else that's pretty tough for
some people to understand number four
you cannot multiply wealth by dividing
it and number five when half of the
people get the idea that they do not
have to work because the other half is
going to take care of them and when the
other half gets the idea that it does no
good work good to work because somebody
else is going to get what they work for
that is the beginning of the end of any
nation
do you love this professor or do you
love this respect to this professor is
that the professor with the mask on or
is that just a random i think that's
just an ad because it's that sheet so
the teacher is a woman instead of a man
so what are your thoughts on this i mean
look it's one of those things where
socialism sounds great in theory right
these all these kids in the class had
like social sounds great but when put
into practice
it ain't so much fun right for
especially for the kids that are trying
hard they're trying to get good grades
and are putting in the effort so i love
that he broke it down into these five
principles
at the end of the day
i think there was a poll out there
this is maybe six months ago
and it's and half the country
young people
thought that socialism was a better no
more more than half more than more than
half of people understand sixty-four
percent was it that much the harvard uh
poll thought that socialism was not bad
was a better um system than capitalism
because they haven't been in the
workforce okay exactly so it's one of
those things where in theory something
sounds good but when you actually
practice it not as much and they've been
around so these kids get indoctrinated
by teachers and the teachers the modern
teacher and i've got teachers in my
family and i always they feel like i'm
always going after him but this is just
truth all right every teacher i've ever
met thinks that they are smarter than
they get paid for right and that's the
basis of their ideology their college
professors specifically are resentful of
the plumber or the truck driver that
makes twice as much as they do because
i'm the smart one so obviously the
system is flawed because if if it
weren't flawed then i would be the rich
one and they would be my underling and
it's like dude you don't underst what
they don't understand and even if you've
ever read marks what people don't get is
you don't get paid for intellect you get
paid for value you can either do
something that nobody else in the world
does you play basketball all of us play
basketball none of us are in the top one
percent of it so we don't get paid to
play basketball right lebron james can
get paid billions of dollars because
he's number one our friend victor that
you uh interviewed he's a million dollar
backgammon player because he's the best
in the world at it no everybody else
plays
20-some years yeah yeah
we're doing a tour together with doubles
in vegas in january
dude he's an awesome dude his wife is
great
but but again nobody else in the world
is getting paid to play backgammon you
got to be the best in the world at it so
if you're not the best in the world at
what you want to do then you have to be
willing to do what other people aren't
willing to do nobody want wakes up in
the morning and wants to be a plumber
but there's a lot of money because
nobody wakes up in the morning and wants
to be a plumber that's what these things
that's what these lessons don't teach
man and when you're looking at a
situation like this with this what that
really wasn't socialism so much it was
this egalitarian utopia man where it's
like we're all going to be the same
together that's nonsensical i don't know
if that's true but i do know it is true
what actually did happen in michigan and
there was one in brooklyn there was a
vegan marxist restaurant where they want
to do a shoe capitalism and they
basically said eat what you want we'll
make it pay us what you think is right
men whatever you think is right women
you get you got to pay uh 22 more than
women do to make up for the wages of
grass here we go they're gone they're
out of business
like it's the most predictable out of
business thing and then they they blame
capitalism for them being out of
business well we can't compete because
the prices keep rising okay
guys this is market level matt what do
you think when i think about things like
this i default to my favorite books at
about which is proverbs and ecclesiastes
why because it's written by the richest
king wisest king who ever lived and
here's what he says about about this
proverbs 13 chapter 4 says the soul of
the lazy man desires and has nothing but
the soul of the diligent shall be made
rich so it depends on how you want to
attack life you want to go and attack
life and say oh i want everybody else to
help me out but i'm willing to
contribute back to society well you
should
not get back anything in return but if
you want to contribute this to that you
want to be diligent you're up you're
getting up you're doing your part and uh
that's probably one of the hardest
things because
you said mention you mentioned earlier
that what's the biggest platform today
the people who are lazy people on the
complaint that's no good that's who's
got the biggest platform the biggest pic
i had the greatest compliment the other
day on my youtube channel in seventh
grade squad somebody says you mr want to
be junior valuetainment
what was that supposed to be you guys
are rich because you have no college
degree so why are you why are you
getting mad at us yeah why are you
getting mad at us let me let me ask you
something on that because i i don't
think we throw around this word lazy i
don't think they're lazy i just don't
think they don't want to do
what they anything they don't desire
doing like they'll yeah nobody does
that's the difference
is the difference so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you